نحن هنا اليوم مع واحدة من أوائل
النساء اللائي خرجن على الطريق هذا الصباح في
جدة ،
هذه روزانا كانت بعيدة ، فكيف
تشعر بالإثارة أنا سعيد للغاية لأنني
لم أتناول وجبة الإفطار ،
لقد خرجت للتو من المنزل وكذلك فعلت  هل
فكرت يومًا أن هذا سيحدث ، نعم
فعلت وأتذكر أنني كنت في السيارة عندما
تلقيت الأخبار التي اتصلت بي صديقي المفضل
على الهاتف المحمول وهي مثل يا إلهي
لن تصدق هذا الأمر كله في
الأخبار التي كنت مثلها  الصراخ في السيارة ،
كيف سيغير هذا حياتك ،
لا أعلم أنه يغير حياتي بالفعل ،
أفكر في الله الآن على جميع
المستويات التي تعرفها مع وجود عائلة مع
وجود إمكانية الوصول
والخيار هو هذا حقًا
هذا ما قلته لي أن لديك
أطفالًا وهذا يمنحك القدرة
على إخراج أطفالك ، يمكنني رؤية
مقعد السيارة بالفعل في الخلف ،
وأعتقد أن أحد الأشياء
الرائعة في القيادة هو أنه يمكنك  اذهب مع
أطفالك واحصل على ذكريات
مثل الذهاب على الطريق  الرحلات الإعلانية ، لذلك فهي أيضًا
شيء يربط الأسرة بالعائلة ، ولكن كما أعتقد أيضًا ،
فإن القيادة مفيدة
للأشياء العملية ولكن في بعض الأحيان ليس فقط
للأشياء العملية مثل أنها لطيفة في
بعض الأحيان يكون لديك فقط الحرية
في الذهاب في رحلة تعرف أن تأخذها  القيادة
لذلك أعتقد أن هذين
الأمرين هما ما هو التالي للمرأة في المملكة
العربية السعودية ،
يا إلهي ، مثل كل ما يحدث ،
إنه الآن أعتقد أنه كل شيء
الآن الآن